I want to start with this question if
someone has actually never seen anything
that you've done before what is the
first thing you'd like them watching and
why I think maybe
uh
maybe
um
supernova
which was a movie I did with Colin Firth
a few years ago
um because I think it's a really
beautiful film
and I like the way Colin and I work
together in in it and I like I just like
the the film I've enjoyed your searching
for Italy um and watching you eat and
I'm just curious how you have not put on
40 pounds
I have very fast metabolism and I
exercise a lot and you
if I'm eating on camera in that show I
don't always
you'll see me eat but I won't eat the
entire thing I mean that would be like
gross so I you know I then you end up
going out to dinner and having proper
you try to regulate your
you're eating I I understand I'm just
saying I I would be putting on a lot of
weight um
so um I heard that your first day of
filming on uh on this film was you
needed to film the rehab scene or
telling Whitney she was going to be
going to rehab and that was your first
day of filming
um what is it is it what is it like
stepping on set that's what your
director told me
um okay what is it like
what is it like stepping on set and the
first scene you do is a really serious
and important scene in the movie yeah
it's it's if you know the script well
and you understand the Arc of the
character it's not
it's not so bad if it's a huge huge
emotional emotional scene that it
becomes a bit harder but this was this
was a more subtle emotional scene
um but I've had that experience many
times making movies so you get used to
it Donald Sutherland told me that in his
contract he makes it so he has to film
something from the middle of the movie
on his first day to make sure because he
feels that uh in the middle of the movie
people are going to buy into whatever
he's selling and he doesn't want to film
the beginning or the end at the
beginning of the shoot
that's a very good idea
very smart that's that's why he's Donald
Sutherland Yeah well yeah you know what
uh one of the things about this is that
I learned a lot about Whitney that I
didn't know watching the movie and I'm
just curious were there were there any
things that really surprised you to
learn about her life that you had no
idea before the shoot well I didn't know
that she was bisexual I didn't know that
I didn't uh and I didn't really know
understand the the extent of the uh
addiction
uh and and and I I really didn't know
that relationship with Clive Davis which
I think is an amazing relationship
everything I I Echo everything you just
said
um I already have to rap I'm just gonna
say man I am a really big fan of your
work I just want to thank you for giving
me your time and good luck with your
speed dating today thank you so much
thank you